all right breaking news now Israel
inching closer to a hostage deal fingers
are crossed with Hamas that could happen
just hours from now and while that's
going on Hollywood haters of the Jewish
state are out in full force case in
point liberal actress Susan Sarandon
trafficking in in plon anti-Semitism
while attending several Pro Palestinian
rallies the Oscar winner joining in on
chants like from The River To The Sea
nice which calls for the destruction of
Israel and now she's mocking Jewish
people who fear for their
safety there are a lot of people that
are afraid afraid of being Jewish at
this time and are getting a taste of
what it feels like to be a Muslim in
this country so often uh subjected to
violence it's important to listen it's
important to have facts try to take a
breath before you answer and if it's
possible have a conversation we need to
cease fire now okay there you go but it
looks like words have consequence say
Hollywood talent agent UTA one of the
biggest in the business says Sarandon is
no longer reped by them and Academia
continues to be assessible of Israel
hatred another case in point Professor
Wake Forest University sparking outrage
over what she posted she posted a vile
fantasy of on social media saying quote
tempted to shoot up for dance parties
just like Hamas terrorist did on October
7th the radical Professor resigning over
that and she's now whining that the
school threw her to the wolves and
disappointed her uh Jesse you feel as
though this is the they Susan sandon has
a
point I'm shocked she got dropped
because this isn't anything new for
Susan Susan called the pope a Nai Susan
called the NYPD fascists so I see what
she's saying here and the head of UTA is
Jewish I believe there's a lot of Jewish
people that work for UTA they were upset
it seemed like they could have seen this
coming and that could have been managed
over many many years but listen I guess
there's a line now everybody knows where
it is but I don't see the comparison
because after 9911 you know perhaps
Muslim Americans were singled out at the
airport but other than that I don't
remember a lot of people chanting in the
streets Gass the Muslims I don't
remember Muslims being murdered like the
guy in a protest in Los Angeles none of
that actually happened they wanted to
put a mosque down by Ground Zero that
was the worst of it from what I recall
now this other Professor this is what I
like to see happen I want to see these
donor donors dangle money in front of
these universities you remember how Joe
Biden dangled a million dollars in front
of Ukraine I'd do that I'd say you're
not getting this million dollars if the
entire creative writing Department isn't
fired and that's how you have to do it
because there's a lot of rancid hate
coming out of these universities right a
source uh uh that I know I talked to
them and that that she apologized
initially and came back and doubled down
the next day Dana and that's when they
said this is the easiest decision ever
you we're you're we're done with you
well and and some of the people that
defended her today said well there's a
First Amendment right but the First
Amendment right keeps you out of jail
right it doesn't mean that you won't
have consequences for things that you
say and I suppose she's wealthy enough
that it doesn't really matter to her
does she really care if UTA drops her
she's probably glad she's like I don't
have to pay that commission anymore fine
see you later um but the other thing is
that happened yesterday Cheryl sanberg
who used to be with Facebook and part of
the Clinton Administration she put out a
video asking women to think about for
one second speaking up on behalf of the
women who were raped in Israel at the uh
at the raid at the ter on the terrorist
attack and it seemed to me like that's
just something that should happen the UN
women's group they still have not said
anything they will not do that and so I
look at some of these people we have a
block later on coming coming up and it's
like some of the for women who have been
successful to just turn such a blind eye
to the suffering of other women
regardless of who they are what they
look like or where they live is really
appalling to me Jessica your thoughts on
the dropping of Susan Sarandon in this
continued craziness on campus I think it
was definitely the right decision um
retracting your apology whether you knew
that she espoused crazy views which
everyone does know um doesn't make a
difference it's abor what she said um it
unfortunately for anti-semites just
continue to fuel the Jews run Hollywood
Jews control all the money thing but you
know what don't care happy to be in
charge happy she got dropped um
something that I've been thinking about
a lot and I know the judge wants to talk
about this aspect of it too so I won't
go on too long about it but is you know
all of these so-called allies of the
Arab world are very quiet as Arabs are
murdered on mass under normal
circumstances when Assad kills millions
and displaces them years year decades
and I thought this was astounding so
Israel was created in 1948 right
necessary because 6 million Jews were
killed in camps or in ovens and since
then 11 million Arabs have been killed
and less than 0.3% of them have been
killed by
Israelis right so the rest of the Arab
world is are the ones who are usually
doing the dirty work here we don't hear
anything about it I mean there are
groups I'm sure that talk about it
people aren't taken to the streets
talking about what's going on in Yemen
or who's being pushed out and the only
difference is that Jews are involved now
and they don't talk for a second about
over 1,200 people were killed like you
said I thought Cheryl samberg's video
was hugely powerful the way that they
were murdered that's not battle that's
not Warfare that is torture Carnage and
Carnage
and great points that was awesome uh
felma and Louise 3 she no longer has to
pay commission so that'll be a big
relief for her uh what are your thoughts
about her look I mean she's always been
a Liberal off-the-wall Liberal I mean I
don't respect her opinion and and I
think it's appropriate that UTA dropped
her that's number one number two uh she
is so worried about um the Muslims I
mean her quote is that you know it it is
um you know they finally get to feel the
Jews finally get to feel the way Muslims
have felt I mean she has no idea what
she's talking about first of all there
are 50 majority Muslim countries in this
world where Muslims can do and say what
they want they can act out their
religion they can live their lives
according to um you know their their
religion and how they want to live there
is one Jewish country and it is a very
small one at that and yet she's so upset
about it and you know as Jessica said
we've been talking about this for years
Isis beheaded tens of thousands of
Muslims nobody marched nobody called for
a ceasefire uh basad and and Gaddafi and
the Saudi Arabians they they killed the
yemenis and nobody says boo but it
reminds me of black lives matter black
lives matter only matter if there's a
cop killing a black life and as it
relates to the Arabs the only time that
the Arab life's matters is if a Jew
kills them but if if a Jew is killing
them pursuant to the laws of war that
are appropriate after you've suffered a
massacre of medieval proportions they
don't even recognize the law so I don't
see this woman as that bright as that
knowledgeable about history about where
we are and about the fact that
anti-Semitism has risen now what is it
400% and she's now worried about it and
you know it even took a a Muslim woman
uh I think her name was um Norah Asam
who talked about the fact that they
don't understand what it's like for us
we can't say in our own country what we
can say in America so shame on Susan Sur
right and plus the whole Arab world will
tell you they'd love homas eradicated
off the face of the Earth and Iran is
the problem fundamentally it's all we're
we're going to be sitting here and it's
all going to be it's going to come down
to Iran without them there is really no
issues hey everyone I'm Emily compano
catch me and my co-hosts Harris vulner
and Kaye mcki on outnumbered every
weekday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or set
your DVR also don't forget to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights